well me or my boyfriend usually disagree
about other boys in my life
so also with friends that i have
well he doesn't really enjoy it when i
go out
for drinks or when i just go out with
them in general
i even tried to introduce him to my
friends
but the first time didn't go so well
yeah
so um some questions do any of those
guys have feelings for you
in the past they have but now not
anymore they pretty much
moved on most of them have a girlfriend
already
and i know i know how that sounds i do
but i want to say that
this [ __ ]
you can't make this [ __ ] up you can't
make it up
you you literally can't make it up oh
i don't get why my boyfriend feels
uncomfortable with some of the guy
friends that i have
did they have feelings for you or really
interested in the past
uh yeah some of them were the reason why
i left
is because if i was on camera i know
your face would have been
horrid listen yeah i don't believe in
poker face i know
i gotta tell all faces i gotta i gotta
poke a face a bit i gotta flush one you
gonna know it
cause i flushed out my expressions so
today's topic we do a lot of instagram
lives where
viewers come on talk to us about stuff
so if you guys wanna be part of one of
these lives
jump on our instagram make sure you hit
that follow button be updated when we go
live we go live a couple times a week
you can come on talk or just witness
what happens but let's watch a video
for one of our lives
did you die are you okay
because i do know there's at least two
that i feel like i'm not safe around
when we're alone
look at my face what the [ __ ] did you
just say to me
we went for feelings to there's two that
i'm not
safe around and you disagree with your
boy about why
so i try to just not be alone with them
in any sort of circumstances in any sort
of
circumstance okay so here's the thing
right whenever i hear this stuff from
girls
all my friends are guys immediately it's
a red flag i'm not saying inherently
something's going on with shady
but this is my been my personal
experience of what i've seen for most
dudes who are friends with girls
when a girl's got a lot of guy friends a
good majority of them want to smash
okay and you can say whatever you want
even if you got a few
often times they want to smash it's very
common okay that's why
when that happens when you break up with
your boy he's like hey what's up
he tries to slide right now i'm not
surprised that there's gonna be a lot of
dudes
uncomfortable with that you're
constantly around dudes who are tempted
by you
right and we're just waiting for an
opportunity
yeah it's not great it's not fun i'm not
saying it's just
but it stands to reason makes a lot of
sense for why a lot of dudes feel
uncomfortable about this
and to pretend like i don't get i don't
get it but you feel unsafe around these
guys so you are
aware of how they look at you if you
feel unsafe
why do you think your boyfriend doesn't
want you to be there he would be a bad
boyfriend he's like oh [ __ ] you feel
unsafe down that dark alley well
off you go by midnight i'm locking the
door good luck
call me in an hour it's like that's a
bad boyfriend so
i don't know i just saw this and i i
thought it was funny
lizzy a shoulder to crying becomes a
dick to write on
true so i understand that your boyfriend
feels unsafe on top of that you know
you know yeah you know
you just disagree but you know stop
you know what they call this they call
it the long game
the long game go ahead it's when you
plant the seed and you wait for it to
sprout
now sometimes it never sprouts sometimes
that seed never sees any sun
sometimes you just need to wait right
but here's the thing like i said
if the breakup never happens maybe you
never get an opportunity yup
right but there's plenty of folks who
wait i'm gonna be just kind enough and
just chill enough to just see and then
if anything oh what happened
how are you doing how you been are you
still with your ex are you still with
your boyfriend
oh you guys are broken up wow what you
been up to
oh where do you work you're still in
town man we should grab a bite i feel
like it's been so long
yeah yeah oh hey come on we know what's
happening
it could take three years five years hey
and then after that it's big
it takes almost effort it takes now
people lay better than that it takes no
effort so plenty of people do that and
plenty of dudes is waiting for it so
yeah i just find it confusing when
ladies look
you all know what something yeah she
knew she knew
the minute she disappeared she's like
it's
and before you disappeared she's like i
know it sounds bad
you knew you know what's funny it was
like women always talk about how men
[ __ ] on women but women [ __ ] on women
way more than we do sometimes
women's [ __ ] on women yeah yeah i don't
even want to be friends with these
[ __ ]
it's like whoa i don't hear guys say
like man i don't even have any male
friends like i'll just make friends with
females i was like what
i feel like men don't understand women
women understand women and they
you know y'all hate each other they all
hate each other
i don't understand that nah b don't
don't
you never hear dudes talk about like man
i would never be friends with other
dudes so say what
i would find that super sensitive like i
said girls are comfortable
i would never be friends with ladies i'm
like where does that come from that's
us i can't be friends with them yeah i
can't work with them
yeah she can't be my boss a lot of
things so that's just funny to me that's
an interesting thing but
hey these are my thoughts you have
anything else i want to add about the
dynamics
cause you got a lot of female friends so
i'm you you know yeah but that's that's
a different dynamic
i believe that amazing a guy that has a
lot of female friends is this different
dynamic because of what you said before
go ahead like the dynamic is very much
different than
a girl having a lot of guy friends why
is it different
because of the dynamics of you know guys
wanting to smash girls that's a smash
too i guess girls want to smash too yeah
but couldn't people say you're the dude
who wants to smash all these ladies
they could they could definitely do that
but
they wouldn't stick around if they
wouldn't feel at least at ease did you
hear that
most of them don't stay when when a
woman like when she don't feel like he's
usually a girl i don't feel like he's
with someone it's not going to stick
around
if she feels like she's threatened or
something like that she's not going to
stick around
and that's pretty much it you know women
know when a guy wants to smash
oh yes they know they feel that yeah
that's that's part of their spidey sense
a woman feel when a dude i mean i mean
it's not their spidey
it's not their spidey sense [ __ ] if i
go on vegas boulevard and i see neon
lights that say strip club i don't have
a spidey sense to know there's half
naked women in there
[ __ ] advertise their interest very
obviously exactly
oh hey what's up they got them eyes yeah
bruh i know when [ __ ] wanted yeah so
it's not a spidey sense it's common
sense
but but it reacts girls react
differently to that here's how you know
a dude wants to smash
okay flip a coin whether it's heads or
tails he wants to smish
it [ __ ] makes me think when i was in
the white and there was
someone would ask the guide if there was
sharks in the water
and the guy sounded like a cowboy was
like well i'm gonna tell you if there's
sharks in the water because we're
wearing canoes right
and kayaks he's like i'm gonna tell you
if there's sharks in the water you're
gonna take your finger like this
you're gonna dip it in the water
take it out mm-hmm
is it salty there's sharks all right so
i'm going over the next ride
[Laughter]
he floored me he was struggling he's
like i would have been working with you
laughing so hard i was dead
you know what that is that's the [ __ ]
who's heard that question so many times
he was the guy was laid back and then
he's like yep they're sharp we're in a
while but
we're in hawaii pacific water you know
what i mean they're gonna be sharks
around here
so yep
salty they're sharks all right so we're
just gonna go over there and do a little
bit of snorkeling all right guys
follow me right he that was the best
dismissal i've seen in years
anyways back to the question i got a
question so women know when when they
know when the guy wants to smash right
and
oftentimes they don't stay if they don't
have an interest right
and guys do stay though
yeah guys do say there's no interest or
whatever they have an interest
everybody says if they have an interest
right but if they don't they don't
and i mean knowing these people i'm like
drake no new friends right i've been
knowing
these people before i was famous famous
so it's not about
fame or whatever what not you know what
i mean it was i was broke broke
you know what i mean so it ain't got
nothing to do with fame ain't got
nothing to do with none of that
so it's a different dynamic right it's
not like they stay where
because they have an incentive or
whatever what not they just they because
whatever
yeah let's go something listen tell us
what you guys think in the comments
below do you guys have male friends we
want to hear from you guys in the
comments
let's go
[Music]
is